well in our lab at Carnegie Mellon we're
developing technologies that improve
mobility especially for people with
stroke or amputation we're taking on
what I think is the singular challenge
in the development of prosthesis and
exoskeletons which is that we don't
really know what they should do to help
the human that's using them we're
developing versatile exoskeleton or
prostheses emulator systems there's a
lightweight device worn on your leg
flexible tether and powerful off board
motor control hardware this means we can
test many ideas for assistance without
overhead of designing a new device there
are millions of people in the world who
experience reduced mobility and a lack
of social engagement and inability to
work because of disabilities that affect
the lower limbs and we are trying to
develop technologies that help them get
around better
[Music]
you